what has Biden done or what are his  views that you think are are good or  that are worth giving a second term to I  I think he's done a lot a lot of good I  I think that uh I mean I could name  several things I think the chips act  which brought manufacturing of computer  chips back the United States I think  that's great for manufacturing here but  also great for uh I think our national  security uh the PAC Deck with the burn  pit thing which heat signed and do law  um the uh the cap on senior uh  prescription drug costs at two thousand  dollars I think that's great I think  there's a lot of old people in the  United States who aren't even buying  drugs that they need because of the  expenses and I I I love the fact that he  signed that new law